Hey youtubers it's Charlie!
This is going to be my Flash Episode 4 video.
Big Firestorm episode, but the end of the
episode should have made you flip your table,
get our of your chair and scream.
It was so much fun.
That's the sign of a good show like when you
get really excited about the big twist in
the episode you mean you get to see a new
firestorm be created firestorm need to but
then it surprises you at the very end in a
way that just makes you crap your pants so
that is my top five WTF moments then I'll
explain the comic book characters and do Easter
eggs all all the stuff we will do all the
things and just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet and don't forget,
there is a new round of the reverse flash
ring giveaway.
I'm just giving away a new ring every week
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video.
So first things first meet Jax Jackson your
new firestorm what they've done is they've
taken a lot of classic Ronnie Raymond from
the comics the witty banter that he had with
the Martin Stein character and combined it
with Jason Rusch and used a different name
like is that I'd I think they're just trying
to avoid any confusion because they already
cast a Jason Rusch on the show but that character
that actor is in so when they want to use
with legends of tomorrow but they want classic
firestorm they want a lot of that fun witty
banter so Jack's is just an amalgam of a lot
of those things they can't do that with season
one of the flash to the be combined a lot
of Wally West run a lot of the humor of the
Wally West from the comics with things names
characters from the Barry Allen era so the
flash TV show just in general is an amalgam
of a lot of different eras of the flash in
the comics one of the issues they bumped up
against when they when they were doing with
the Ronnie Raymond firestorm is an in the
comics Ronnie's kind of like a dumb jock character
but they turned Robbie Amell's character into
something of an engineer's you lose some of
the energy that the classic Ronnie had in
the comics so so Jack's is kind of a course
correction in that sense fronds is a great
actor he was in attack the block with John
Boyega who is blowing it up in the Star Wars
universe of it's gonna be great is going to
be a lot of fun having him on the show but
primarily he's going to be alleges a tomorrow
character definitely expect to see them again
in an episode before the midseason finale
the midseason finale on the flash is going
to be the Vandal Savage episode went when
they cut IT up the need for the legends of
tomorrow team up until then there's going
to use episodes to explain Walvis characters
are like the next big one will probably end
up meeting will be Hawkgirl and Hawkman everybody
high five Jack's Walkman to the team the big
villain they gave him to defeat was talk of
Mark Henry Hewitt talk, he's a classic firestorm
zone from the comics notice that Cisco didn't
object when Caitlin gave him the name is Cisco
has been pretty nice the season about something
other characters name villains let's try to
not step on his toes too much though, on to
number 4 Iris versus her mother so that I
actually really like what they did with iris'
character this week this is this is generally
this is going to be irises big thing this
season is fixing her family just like Barry's
mission in season one was fixing his family
can have this really good speech with Jax
Jackson as it was a really great Danielle
Panabaker moment where she was talking about
possibilities right in front of you being
a part of something bigger you could totally
reapportion that to irises storyline take
the chance on her mother for the opportunity
to be part of something bigger you're making
her family bigger literally and figuratively
the way she ended things didn't sound very
hopeful so that distal like a couple hurdles
that Iris has to jump over emotionally before
she's going to be ready to let this all in
but I feel like giving her the Wally West
reveal was one of the best things they did
for her in the episode using irises abilities
as a good reporter like she's you pretty good
reporter to find out about Wally West which
it sounds like Joe doesn't know about yet
so moving onto number three meet Wally West
Mystery child of Joe West that irises mother
this might've been a little bit confusing
because irises like this baby was born eight
months after you left Central city who is
the father I think it would've been a very
different story if arson said 10 months after
she left Central city then you definitely
would've been like okay okay this is definitely
somebody else's child but I do think she and
Joe did the deed before she bailed and took
off so Wally West is Joe's son is gonna be
like a big smack in the face for Joe but of
course I think the Joe's gonna take some of
his own advice and accept Wally to the family
he has a habit of adopting rescue puppies
Jimmy just look at Barry he like the ultimate
rescue puppy so courses can invite Wally West
and it is certain point your maybe not right
away maybe not right on the spot but is simply
can happen that that just a good person that
Joe is and if it wasn't clear when irises
mother said that she had disease in they only
gave her a year with their kind of saying
is is that she's probably going to die at
the end of this season like shall live to
the end of the shows year Iris was totally
mature about the whole thing but if you really
want to know what she thinks of her mother
just think about the way she speaks to her
my father told me you said you were sick she
that she doesn't refer to her as your marriage
is a hey mom so I think eventually you know
like what once they heal their family shall
start calling her mom that's when you'll know
she'll have fully accepted her mom and but
I'd I think that's going to take most of the
season to do on the number two though Harrison
wells is back he's walking in making everyone
put their pants don't tell buried nobody tell
Barry about them that was so great when Joe
was like you cannot tell Barry and Patty just
like I don't, I don't do the lion so well
not not so much that's just the show telling
you that Patty is like a really good person
and they really want you to trust her because
she's so bad at lying if you are really good
liar and then and pry be harder to trust her
but I think the device that Harrison stole
from Mercury labs was the device that he used
to say Barry like the giant Taser weapon in
this is real deal King shark bait they didn't
just because they're not to be doing at all
the time it was meant to be a special thing
that Harrison wells of earth two is in an
evil character I mean he's he's basically
good like fill in for Martin Stein whenever
alleges a tomorrow picks up to be like the
mature advisor on the team he is going to
be a big douche bag before the particle accelerator
explosion he was a big hero of berries so
now Barry is meeting that hero the actual
Harrison wells he's not in Eobard Thawne disguise
is not the reverse flash so berries gonna
have to deal with meeting his hero and then
finding out that his heroes complete Dick
had but Tom Cavanagh is a series regular he's
going to be here for most of the season you
know idea was can happen to him at the end
hopefully he won't die because they want to
meet or three Harrison wells is like Tom Cavanagh
is trying to challenge Tatiana Maslany on
orphan black for the number of characters
played by the same actor in the same show
but just address Barry and Patty I know it
was pretty obvious in the episode that their
seating a relationship between those two there
is like a date night episode coming no idea
they're going to turn Patty into hot pursuit
of any anytime she might just be regular Patty
for the rest of season the way she is now
the way Diggle doesn't have superpowers but
it's kind of a superhero she's just kind like
a Diggle type character just a normal bad
ass on their own have been seeing some awesome
patties zoom theories I do like the idea that
you know just like the fun they could have
with playing really good Patty against really
evil Patty but again I think that zoom himself
is a male character for speaking of zoom onto
my number one WTF table flipping amazing moment
manager giant freaking shark on the flash
this is so awesome just in case you never
read it there was a flash season zero comic
book it was a tie in with season one of the
show I don't know if they're still doing it
or not but they introduced this shark character
in that comic book during that story it gets
recruited for the suicide squad so my understanding
is that it was supposed to be King shark but
this version of the character is from earth
two so there might be some some slight changes
I was actually really excited for Patty to
save Barry as the flash she doesn't know the
berries the flash by the way they Harrison
wells revealed the end was even better is
like one WTF rolling into another WTF we go
from Wally West oh my God to King shark holy
should two Harrison wells WTF C has let me
know which WTF reveal was your favorite in
the episode I'm he wasn't seeing the new firestorm
we can saw him coming that was in his big
of a surprise was it Wally West was a giant
freaking shark I think this episode is definitely
get to be one of the most fun ones from season
two to rewatch but I am expecting some even
better step to becoming in the second half
of the season but we know we have a big Grodd
episode coming to the really funny strike
but I totally totally love it was kind of
a small moment but at the beginning when they
turned the reverse flash is wheelchair into
a super cane for Martin Stein to stabilize
him super wheelchair become super cane and
that's kind of the end of the reverse flash
is technology they the use it to build a new
containment device the producers said they've
already got rid of Gideon like there's no
Gideon as star labs anymore they can we can
ask the questions about the future the funny
thing is is that at the end of this week's
episode I made like the same like oh my God
face as I did at the end of walking dead on
Sunday night for a completely different reasons
totally different types of WTF so was can
happen next is I'm still catching up with
Supergirl in a couple of the videos be sure
to subscribe to get everything what white
as way for that I just posted my Gotham video
you can click here to watch that metahuman's
coming to Gotham different metahuman's then
from The Flash, I don't I think they can share
character and you can click here for my WTF
walking dead video thank you so much for watching
everybody high five and I'll see you guys
tomorrow!